hey there friends
so I tried out an interesting experiment
this past month um and I learned a lot
of interesting things from it things
about myself things about online
communities and I wanted to share those
with you today because I spent the last
month for the first time in the entire
history of my
channel not ever looking at the view
counts of any of my videos and it was a
really interesting experience here from
Drex Factor Poise sharing with you the
love of pois spinning and flow Arts to
benefit your body and brain and today I
am uh talking about an interesting thing
inside my brain and I'm pretty sure
inside of the brains of other people as
well but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyara light toys spinballs and
Ultra for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you canar learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- buus friend of the
channel Becca Becken thank you so very
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission so it has been a really
really stressful week and uh I am
definitely grateful that I thought ahead
and booked myself an hour in the dance
studio to kind of go unwind and just
have some time for me so while I'm
walking down there kind of want to tell
you this story and uh tell you what came
of it as well so context
here about a month ago um I had a really
really good but also really intense
conversation uh with my girlfriend and
she said something that I think is going
to live rentree in my head for a very
very long time namely I was stressing
really really hard about trying to find
topics for videos that I thought were
going to be really appealing to people
and you know second guessing a lot of
topics that I was really interested in
pursuing and she said to me that she
believes that I sometimes have a
tendency to hold myself back when I go
seeking those topics that I think are
going to be popular that is when I'm
seeking
to increase the view counts on those
videos that sometimes I'm not very true
to myself in the process so after
sitting with that for a day or
two I decided to try an
experiment I was going to give myself
one month in which I was not allowed to
look at the view count for any video
that I posted to Instagram or
YouTube um and and you know caveats here
of course like you know there's just
some stuff that when working on the back
end of YouTube it's quite difficult not
to see you can'ts sometimes but by and
large I was going to try to as much as
possible avoid look looking at that
section of the screen and I wasn't going
to seek that information out
um I was going to do my best to kind of
just sit in uncertainty
and see how that felt and see how that
changed or didn't change my relationship
with my content and my audience and it
was really challenging like really
really challenging there were definitely
times when I desperately wanted to know
how particular videos were behaving and
also too just some parts of that are
kind of built into my day like anytime I
post a new video one of the first things
I do in the morning is go check to see
what the view account for it is like
how's it performing did it make it into
the top five videos that I posted in the
past
month is there anything I can do to push
its performance a little bit more and uh
all of a sudden that part of my routine
just disappeared and I had to find new
ways of interacting with my content so
one of the first and most obvious things
that this changed for me about the game
was it changed the stuff that I was
interested in making
once I was no longer hung up on how many
views the thing was going to get I kind
of shifted my thinking to be like well
if I'm not thinking about what people
want to receive from me what is it that
I want to say what is it that I want to
put out there into the world what are
the things that I want to share and I'll
be honest with you in a lot of cases
this meant that the videos that I chose
to make and publish were things that I
felt a lot better about than normal not
only that
I also like kind of put myself more in
the perspective of somebody who was
watching the videos themselves and just
being all
like what is my experience being a part
of this uh what are some things that I
can do better at what would make this
experience more enjoyable for me and I
actually came up with some cool ideas as
I was working through that uh stuff that
was fun to edit stuff that was kind of
fun to present and that you know it
seemed to me like a good way to flex my
muscles as an editor and a content
creator and that was really fun and the
other big thing that changed was that in
the absence of having a view count as a
form of feedback in terms of how the
video was received I wound up spending a
lot more time engaging in the comment
section I think I replied to nearly
every comment that I got especially on
the newer videos in the past month and
it was kind of cool to forge what I
think were some more direct relationship
sh with people in my audience as a
result like no lie I think that that's a
thing that I'm going to hold on to from
here on out and probably the thing that
I was most surprised by was how much
less stress I have felt about releasing
videos in the past month normally when I
go to bed the night before a video goes
live I'm rolling through in my head
thinking did I create the best thumbnail
is the description going to work is it
going to pick up the right keywords and
all that and then of course when I wake
up my heart is just pounding it's like
oh did the video pop off did the video
pop off and depending upon what it looks
like I either feel a bunch of relief
that yes thank God it was real well
received or disappointment seeing that a
video that I worked really really hard
on hasn't found an audience and that
kind of cycle of stress and either
relief or discouragement went away and
that's that's really a new experience
for for me cuz literally for the entire
time that I've been doing this I cannot
ever remember a time when I didn't feel
some stress uploading and posting a new
video it's kind of nice to not feel that
but the news was not all positive
because as it turns out when you don't
care about the view counts then the view
counts tend to go down uh this was
definitely not a banner month for my
content on YouTube or on Instagram there
were a couple outliers of course but by
and large as it turns out when I'm
focusing on content that satisfies me
rather than content that I think might
satisfy other people tends not to do a
great job of satisfying other people and
that's a thing that I'm honestly trying
to figure out what to do with because
one of the things that I originally
thought of as making my channel special
and making me special as a content
creator especially amongst flow artists
was that I looked at the videos that I
was producing not just as being know
something to fill up my ego like I I
almost never posted performance videos
but as a service that I could do for
people in the community something that
would give people access to ideas that
they wanted or you know helping
beginners get started on their po
Journey with the best tutorials that I
could
create that was a big Cornerstone of a
lot of the growth that I had with my
channel even up until like 2020 or so
and thinking about producing videos is
something that is more about satisfying
me creates a kind of tension there
and I feel less stress in that position
but at the same time I also kind of feel
like it's almost a little bit more
selfish in a lot of ways like if the
content is there to satisfy only me why
do I even have to post it online in the
first place you know I can just sit at
home and watch things that I've created
that I think are pretty
cool there's definitely some stuff to
unpack from that so what exactly will I
do with this information going forwards
well I think at the very least that
granting myself permission to not be
stressed about the performance of my
videos when they drop is a good thing
for me
overall I like feeling less stressed in
the morning I like feeling less pressed
about the things that I create I think
living in
that kind of constant sense of stress
for the past decade has not been good
for me um but you know at the same time
there are things that we sacrifice in
the process of that and I've really got
to spend some time evaluating how many
of those things that I sacrifice are
things that I'm willing to let go of and
how many of them are just kind of you
know part part of the
uh part of the uh part part of the whole
soup and it's hard to have the good
parts without sometimes the bad parts I
don't know I think that there's also a
deeper question in conversation for me
in particular to work through and all
that
because unlike many other people I see
posting to social media like when I look
at view counts or likes I've never seen
that as validation for me as an
individual I always think of it more as
this is a certain number of people who
found something that I created helpful
this is a bunch of people telling me
that I created something that had a
positive impact on their
lives and I don't think that that is a
negative way of looking at things but at
the same time there's clearly a tension
there in terms of the stress that I feel
in trying to deliver that to people so
maybe there's a piece of my ego there
that I need to uh that I need to kind of
dredge up and interrogate and work to
understand a little bit better and of
course there is always that question of
where does the balance lie between
creating things that satisfy me versus
the things that satisfy other people I
think ideally those would be both the
same thing but in my experience they're
very frequently not so which one gets
priority at any given time it's a good
question but also one that I think going
to have to interrogate in more depth in
another video because I am pulling up on
the dance studio right now and I cannot
wait to have this next hour to work
through my feelings with bare feet on a
Marley that's going to be glorious what
do you all think have you ever done a
similar experiment have you ever
deliberately just like posted online and
not bother to check the views of the
light counts I'm really curious what
happened to you as a result leave me a
comment and let me know and if you got
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to help other people find it keep the
conversation going and to help my
channel
[Music]
grout this video would never have been
possible without my amazing patreon
supporters in particular I'd love to
give a sh shout out to my flow patrons
who are listed on screen right now if
you like the videos that I produce about
flow arts and a variety of other
different types of topics uh there's an
easy way to make sure that I create more
of them and that is to go sign up to
support me over on patreon at
patreon.com direct Factor poy I have a
whole host of awesome rewards available
there and even better than that you'll
be supporting me continuing to make work
like this so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to check
out some other videos I have done on the
topic of being a content creator and all
the complicated things that come with
that I will go ahead and Link you to a
playlist of those videos down in the
description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching I hope you
get out to Flo day and I'll see you with
a new video real soon take care now
peace